i have already put down the deposit do
you understand how a deposit works
mike i am not having fire eaters in a
paper warehouse
it's casino night like las vegas or fire
eaters all over the place
except my warehouse well actually it's
my warehouse actually it's owned by
beekman properties and dunder mifflin is
four years into a seven year lease
why are you here when daryl was coming
you said you wanted me here for
protection
that i said not that
we just have a lot of stuff down there
that could be stolen
that's ironic what that you are afraid
why because i'm from the hood dink and
flicker
thinking flicker i told mike some uh
some phrases to help with his
interracial conversations
you know stuff like fleece it out going
mach 5
dinking flicker you know things as
negroes say
give me something
oh yeah uh i thought of a handshake too
ladies and gentlemen
widows and widowers welcome to the all
ages piano lounge adele's only show
i'm horatio velveteen dealt name this
little song i wrote myself
call it rosa rosarosa goes like this
rosa
[Music]
and the lighting is way too sexy to see
anything
right there on the floor is the man
you're looking for
he's right in front of you a little bit
to the left my left my left my left my
left
come on this way he's in the red church
no not the asian dude i'm talking about
a bright red shirt
that's the man you're looking for that's
the man you've been looking for
i got a physical love song people come
on
this is the love song where'd it go
well that ends my show all of a sudden
you've been a great crowd
thank you very much think of me when you
smush
jake help me i don't want to die i'm
still on second season game of thrones
all right let's just put the knife down
okay there's no murder in the all ages
piano lounge screw you
pig that is not a very all ages thing to
say you just don't get the vibe here at
all
nice grab that cord let's get his arms
come here
you just got tanked by my girlfriend
sorry i know that sounded really gross
but it was actually awesome
you okay judy judy
no no no no no no
peralta thanks for saving my life no
judy
don't do this all right again
oh it's hard mike
breakups hurt we didn't break it up
sometimes when i'm down like this
it helps to sing the blues okay
[Music]
hello i followed all your rules
i'm unarmed i'm not wearing a wire
i came alone there's no backup
come on man i need your help to take
down your brother
doug judy the pontiac bandit hey baby
nice legs why are your boxes so you
would know i'm not wearing a wire
your buddy scott said i had to ah that
makes sense scott's a perv
hey scott wherever you watch it from go
home
sorry man that's what's so important i'm
looking for your foster brother george
hate the guy stole from my mom burned
our house down
worst of all he ran off with my lp of
phil collins no jacket required
it's my favorite album i haven't heard
in 20 years i mean
can't you just stream it can't do that
to phil cecilia demands vinyl
right vinyl and whatnot okay well george
is a murderer now and he just escaped
from prison we think he might be trying
to flee the country
you want me to help you catch him like
when x-men teamed up with magneto to
stop apocalypse i heard that one was bad
wasn't great i still want to see it
though i'll watch it again
does that mean you're in course i am
damn it feels good to be on the same
team for once
cop and criminal working together we
need a theme song
the pontiac bandit and jager cops oh
taking down crooks in the streets where
they live flooding with girls who are
hopping a bath
there's a talking police dog that helps
them solve crime okay
ready everybody hey brad
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
she you ahead
i wanted to leave quietly it seemed
dignified
but having kevin grind up on my front
while aaron pretend to hunt me from
behind
is more accurate tribute to my ears here
i'm gonna miss these guys the outfit is
beautiful but it doesn't really say
miami what does say miami
are you sure this is culturally okay for
me we're gonna find out all right
hey guys jan is ready for you
okay bring it home now and don't forget
the new black man phrase i told you
bippity poppy give me the zombie yes sir
remember that
i'll be right outside if you need me all
right
yeah i taught mike some new phrases i
want him to get the razor
just can't help myself what's next for
you doug judy
i'm turning over new leaf gonna live
that honest life
maybe open up a bakery buy a little
house invest in my retirement you're
gonna go back to stealing cars
immediately aren't you that's very much
on the table yeah okay
i'm gonna miss you man i'm gonna miss
you brother goodbye little bible
goodbye papa
cool all right all right peace out peace
good to see you man
[Music]
[Music]
i was under the impression that this was
going to be a wrap
let's wrap okay daryl wow
you need to learn a lot about your own
culture i'll make you a mix
great so i wake in the morning and i
step
outside and i'll
[Music]
oh
you